UGH, MAN I REALLY HAD TO GET OUT
OF THE HOUSE.
- I WAS GLAD YOU CAME OUT.
- I APPRECIATE IT FOR REAL.
- LOOK HERE,
YOU CHECK THIS GIRL OUT, MAN.
SHE IS FINE.
- SHE AIGHT.
- REALLY?
- HEY, MAN, I AM GOING TO GO
TO THE BATHROOM.
- OKAY, MAN.
SEE YOU IN A BIT.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
I TOLD MYSELF THIS MORNING
I WASN'T GONNA FALL IN LOVE.
YOU WENT AND MADE ME BREAK
MY ONLY RULE.
I'M GONNA TAKE THAT
RIGHT QUICK--
I AM GOING TO TAKE THAT.
I'M GOING TO USE THAT.
OKAY.
[chuckles]
- OH, HEY, WHAT'S UP, MAN?
YOU JUST GOT HER NUMBER, HUH?
- YEAH, CHEYENNE.
- OH, IS THAT HER NAME?
- YEAH, SHE WAS FLY-Y.
- THAT'S THE GIRL
I WAS TALKING ABOUT.
- OH, SNAP. ARE YOU SERIOUS?
- YEAH, DUDE.
- OH, I'M SORRY.
- IT AIN'T NO THING, MAN.
FORGET IT.
THERE'S PLENTY OF HOTTIES HERE.
- I JUST THOUGHT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT SOMEONE ELSE.
- CHECK HER OUT.
[mouths words]
- I'M NOT A SPORTS MAN,
BUT...
THINK ME AND YOU
COULD TOUCH DOWN LATER,
IF YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M SAYING.
[chuckles] AM I BEING STUPID?
BUT FOR REAL THOUGH.
JUST GIVE ME YOUR NUMBER,
WHATEVER.
THANK YOU, GIRL.
I'MA TAKE THAT FROM YOU.
- HOW DID YOU GET
OVER HERE SO FAST?
- HUH?
- NOTHING.
IT JUST SEEMED LIKE YOU--
- OH, DAMN.
THAT REPORTER IS SMOKIN' HOT.
WHAT THE [bleep]?
[ominous music]
♪
NO.
NO!
[chuckles madly]
HUH?
YEAH.
NO.
NO!
- HEY, BABY.
- HOW ARE YOU--
ARE YOU DOING THAT?
- HONEY, WHAT'S WRONG?
- OH, BABY, I LOVE YOU.
I'M SORRY.
I WAS OUT, I WAS LOOKING
AT OTHER WOMEN TONIGHT.
BUT YOU ARE ALL THERE IS.
ALL RIGHT,
I LOVE YOU.